yesterday in an interview on CBS's Face
the Nation the president again showered
a dictator with praise this time it was
North Korean dictator Kim jong-un
referring to him as a quote smart cookie
of course Kim jong-un is the tyrannical
despot that runs North Korea with an
iron fist through a cult of personality
forcing his people to worship him
constantly commuting committing human
rights abuses running for the world's
most oppressive tyrant and here's Donald
Trump commenting on Kim jong-un I have
no idea I can tell you this a lot of
people don't like when I say it but he
was a young man of 26 or 27 when he took
over from his father when his father
died
he's dealing with obviously very tough
people in particular the generals and
others and at a very young age he was
able to assume power a lot of people I'm
sure tried to take that power away
whether it was his uncle or anybody else
and he was able to do it so obviously
he's a pretty smart cookie
he's a smart cookie because he was born
into an autocratic dynasty where power
is handed down from one generation to
the next and father to son Kim jong-un
was next in line to take power over
after Kim jong-il died that power was
handed to him and because of that he's a
smart cookie and tough and commendable
according to Donald Trump yeah Trump
talks about Kim jong-un as if he's a
child of some sort I think a few weeks
ago he tweeted something to the effect
that North Korea has to start behaving
and now he's a smart cookie so of course
you don't have to treat Kim jong-un with
any sort of respect but if you're the
president you should probably be a
little bit more diplomatic and not
communicate via Twitter this is also
insane but it makes perfect sense
because Trump is who he is because of
the real-estate Empire and small loan of
a million dollars that his father gave
him right Trump has to believe that
camera jong-un deserves praise for what
he got from his dad because Trump wants
to believe the same thing about himself
if this doesn't convince Trump
supporters that Trump is unbalanced or
at least that he has no ability
whatsoever to think before
speaks even when publicly talking about
the antagonists of the United States I
don't know what will and I'm not even
saying that Kim jong-un is stupid
intellectually but you don't have to be
a genius to inherit power in a country
that under fear of death has been taught
to worship your family right that
doesn't exactly take intelligence yeah
it's certainly one of these things that
these men both want to take credit for
but if you just win the genetic lottery
and assume a lot of fortune or fame or
in Kim Jong Un's case power yeah you
don't really get much credit for that I
completely agree and there are other
parallels between Trump and Kim jong-un
Kim jong-un is an entitled man-child
with an incredible amount of unearned
power who's blindly revered by his
followers
that's pretty damn similar to Donald
Trump so I actually am NOT hugely
surprised that Donald Trump sees Kim
jong-un and maybe sees a little bit of
himself in Kim Jong Un's situation there
send me your thoughts about this because
a lot of people are reacting to this in
a way that seems to ignore the realities
of Trump and a lot of this makes perfect
sense to me
they both have ridiculous hairstyles
that's another point that's a good
similar that there are any number of
similarities between Cambridge Anggun
and Donald Trump